eccoci qui
nel bel mezzo della storia e di un
evento epocale che ricorderemo a lungo
per la seconda volta con la sensazione
di esserne usciti
ricordate
ci sentivamo un po così anche alla fine
dell'estate 2020
il peggio sembrava essere passato
il calo dei decessi e dei contagi ci
aveva fatto ben sperare
io provo un po quella sensazione
che si prova guardando al futuro
con la consapevolezza che abbiamo
trascorso una
vicenda epocale tragica ma anche unica
e che se ne siamo usciti caspita allora
possiamo possiamo cambiare il mondo le
nostre vite
possiamo migliorarle
no
non avete anche voi questa percezione
o forse
forse prevarrà il nostro istinto di
conservazione no la nostra voglia di
toccare di tornare al vecchio mondo alle
vecchie abitudini
in fondo abbiamo un rapporto con il
progresso piuttosto complicato
gli americani hanno bisogno del telefono
ma noi no non la gran bretagna noi siamo
pieni di messengers boy
diceva nel 1878 sir william prec chief
engineer del servizio postale britannico
o ancora
ma il cavallo è qui per restare
ma l'automobile una novità è un
capriccio si esprimeva così il
presidente della michigan savings bank e
lo diceva ad horas rackham l'avvocato di
henry ford che era stato invitato ad
investire nella nascente casa
automobilistica no no non investo
l'automobile non durerà a lungo
ma non c'è bisogno di scomodare i grandi
scettici
mio padre ad esempio a metà degli anni
80 alla presentazione del compact disc
si spese in lunghissime arringhe per
decretarne il fallimento perché lui
puntava tutto su quella
impercettibile graffietto che lo avrebbe
reso immediatamente inutilizzabile
naturalmente dopo una settimana arrivo a
casa con il primo cd che gli ovini nella
mia vita era celentano e lo stiamo
ancora ascoltando
ma il progresso non passa soltanto
attraverso gli oggetti no
passa anche attraverso i nostri
comportamenti
l'organizzazione della vita sociale
se vi faccio vedere alcune immagini che
cosa pensate
o ancora questa
ditemi
chi di voi sta ancora vivendo queste
situazioni al lavoro alzi la mano
nessuno o pochissimi una 2
nessuno le big
4 5 6 7
8 va beh insomma magari aspettando
qualche minuto in più sareste diventati
tantissimi invece chi pensa che
appartengano definitivamente al passato
che non vedremo mai più nulla di tutto
ciò gente che corre a timbrare il
carrello il cartellino chi pensa che
siano definitivamente
abbandonate quanti di voi
fortunatissimi
insomma in ogni caso non possiamo negare
che abbiano segnato le nostre esperienze
lavorative
no che i nostri modelli organizzativi
siano figli di quell'ansia di controllo
e quella di quella sorta di
compravendita del tempo
eppure eppure quel mondo quelle
relazioni non hanno portato soltanto
risultati positivi vediamo insieme il 41
per cento dei lavoratori e lavoratrici
italiani ad esempio soffre di stress da
lavoro correlato e sono 640 4.800 tra
gli infortuni sul lavoro denunciati
all'inail nel 2019 di cui circa il 18
per cento nel tragitto di andata a casa
lavoro
sì perché in italia abbiamo fretta noi
vogliamo finire tutto tutto alla svelta
no
insomma l'italia
subito dopo grecia estonia è il paese
dell'area euro dove si lavorano più ore
alla settimana in media 33 sono tre ora
in più del resto d'europa
in italia c'è tanto da fare c'è lavoro
per tutti
sicuri
nel 2019 la percentuale di occupati in
italia è del 59 per cento
il 14 per cento in meno della media
europea se parliamo di occupazione
femminile
il tasso medio di europee europeo di
occupazione femminile è prossimo al 70
per cento
quello italiano è del 50 per cento
però se parliamo di genere femminile
l'italia ha sempre coltivato il valore
della famiglia no per noi la natalità è
un valore è una missione
più o meno nel 2019 il 73 per cento
delle dimissioni
nel primo anno di vita del figlio ha
riguardato donne di cui 21 mila perché
non sono riuscite a conciliare la vita
il lavoro e infine la ciliegina sulla
torta
dal 2015 l'italia è ultima nella
classifica europea per nuove nascite
insomma un quadro non del tutto
confortante
io ricordo che all'inizio degli anni
parlare di welfare di benessere al
lavoro work life balance conciliazione
flessibilità degli orari di lavoro era
un tabù era roba per pochi eletti per le
multinazionali peraltro guardate sempre
con un po di sospetto e senso di
inferiorità dalle da tanti aziende
italiane
il responsabile del personale era una
figura ritenuta superflua o necessario
solo in caso di tagli all'organico
direttore del personale cosa ci serve ma
spieghiamo noi le persone come si lavora
ecco il come si lavora e come si sta al
lavoro è sempre stata considerata una
questione meramente tecnica
qualcosa però in quegli anni cominciava
a muoversi e qualche azienda cominciava
a sperimentare qualche misura di
avanguardia ne cito alcune tra tante
telecom microsoft o tetrapak san
pellegrino nel 2005 san pellegrino
all'interno del progetto primavera
consentì a due suoi collaboratori di
lavorare a distanza
glielo permise perché voleva provare a
capire che cosa succedesse
agevolandoli nella conciliazione vita
lavoro
quelle sperimentazioni furono le prime
che poi diedero alla luce i primi
accordi integrativi sulla flessibilità
degli orari di lavoro
il tema in quegli anni non era nuovo il
problema era che era sempre stato
affrontato o in una logica e con un
approccio filantropico lo facciamo per
senso del dovere per lo stesso di
giustizia nei confronti dei nostri
dipendenti oppure in una logica
avversaria le se io vinco tu perdi e
quindi l'azienda aveva la percezione che
tutelando che facendo qualcosa per i
propri collaboratori questo si sarebbe
tradotto in un aggravio di costi mentre
le persone che lavoravano e spesso il
sindacato alla sola prospettiva di una
idea di business o di profitto
immediatamente collegava una detrazione
una riduzione delle proprie tutele
noi invece pensavamo che esistessero
soluzioni che potevano combinare il
vantaggio per le aziende e anche per i
lavoratori
qualcosa succede tra il 2010 e il 2014
si comincia a lavorare a un disegno di
legge
che sfocerà nel 2017 nella legge 81 di
cui voglio leggere qualche passaggio con
voi a cui tengo
innanzitutto la legge dice che è il
lavoro agile ha un duplice scopo di
incrementare la competitività e
agevolare la conciliazione dei tempi di
vita e di lavoro e che la prestazione
può essere eseguita in parte all'interno
e in parte all'esterno dei locali
aziendali senza precisi vincoli di
orario di luogo di lavoro è semplice
andate a leggere l'originale
non è una legge complicata obbliga dieta
no no mette in sicurezza una possibilità
la possibilità di scegliere dove e
quando lavorare
certo a patto che quella decisione sia
il frutto dell'intesa tra datore di
lavoro e il proprio collaboratore cosa
succede negli anni immediatamente
successivi
che sperimenta il lavoro agile dice beh
mi ha cambiato la vita sembra banale ma
non dover trascorrere tre ore nel
traffico anche per un solo giorno alla
settimana ovvero sollievo
mi fa stare bene pensare che riducendo i
miei spostamenti è come se avessi
piantato dieci alberi
risparmio 50 km 80 minuti al giorno
posso andare a fare una corsa tra una
riunione e l'altra o ridotto le spese
per la palestra da baby sitter e la
lavanderia
lavorare senza interruzioni con
obiettivi chiari scadenze stabilite
ho migliorato la qualità dei miei
progetti la mia produttività la
concentrazione
nel 2019
l'osservatorio smart working del
politecnico di milano calcola che gli
smart worker sono 570 mila il 20 per
cento in più rispetto al 2018 è quasi
fatta
io e stefania cazzarolli
compagna di vita professionale
raccogliamo tutti i dati a nostra
disposizione le evidenze
abbiamo a disposizione un campione di 30
mila rispondenti
e andiamo a cercare un editore per il
nostro libro dal titolo
smart working
l'unico modo di lavorare è possibile
ancora
ancora smart working
ma è un tema assolutamente frazionato no
ma ormai
tutti fanno smart working
e poi è già stato detto tutto cosa
aggiungereste
infine vi suggerisco il titolo un po
audace
no no no non è audace non è audace è
esattamente quello che sta succedendo
la rivoluzione tecnologica ci sta
travolgendo sta investendo tutti i
settori produttivi
ormai si si fanno diagnosi sicura
distanza si producono macchine si
progettano si collaudano si controllano
a distanza non possiamo più evitare
l'evidenza
noi volevamo spargere il verbo e
spiegare al mondo nel più breve tempo
possibile che quella era la strada unica
inevitabile la flessibilità
la produttività non passa attraverso le
ore passate in ufficio ma attraverso il
saper dare degli obiettivi in sapere
comunicare ai propri collaboratori
coinvolgerli
ingaggiarli formarli e alla fine
fidandosi di loro si fidandosi di loro
qualcuno si fidò di noi e poi alla fine
in realtà il nostro libro venne
pubblicato con un titolo ovviamente
diverso
e siamo al 2019 tutti noi sappiamo cosa
accade dopo
no noi con virus la storia del virus che
è stato creato in laboratorio non
c'entriamo
noi pensavamo che già il virus del
conservatorismo fosse pericolosissimo è
però arriva il covip
e ci impone un nuovo modo di lavorare
non possiamo negare che anche dal punto
di vista professionale e lavorativo qual
cosa sia successo
è vero
è vero nonostante i disagi nonostante la
difficoltà delle relazioni e il dover
lavorare a casa spesso dovendosi
occupare contemporaneamente nei nostri
figli ma incredibilmente paradossalmente
in quella costrizione
abbiamo sperimentato una nuova forma di
libertà
è bastato
no
no no non sono bastati anni di ricerche
e di sperimentazioni di aziende
illuminate di libri non è bastata
neppure una pandemia
gli scettici del lavoro agile ci
circondano
il dibattito di questi giorni è sotto
gli occhi di tutti
e quindi che dire
beh
che non riporteremo il dentifricio nel
tubetto e cito
un illustre collega del politecnico di
milano
perché sono successe tra le tante tre
cose importantissime le aziende le
aziende hanno scoperto che lo smart
working conviene e piace anche a loro
perché possono al contempo essere più
efficienti produttive e far star bene i
loro collaboratori
i manager hanno scoperto che possono
fidarsi del loro del loro team e possono
verificare il raggiungimento dei
risultati attraverso il criterio che non
sia le ore trascorse in ufficio
e poi soprattutto voi noi abbiamo
scoperto che un'altra vita è possibile
e non siamo più disposti a rinunciare a
quelle che abbiamo scoperto essere le
nostre nuove priorità avere ritmi di
vita sostenibili trascorrere più tempo
con le persone a cui teniamo e lavorare
in modo efficace produttivo
non siamo più disponibili a cedere il
nostro tempo senza uno scopo
ok non possiamo dire che lo smart
working è la panacea di tutti i mali non
lo stiamo dicendo no un mondo abbiamo
non funziona automaticamente non è
perfetto dipende da come lo applichiamo
però però non possiamo più negarne
l'esistenza
come per il fuoco la ruota il computer
l'elettricità è arrivato per cambiarci
la vita ma come con il fuoco la ruota il
computer l'elettricità noi ci possiamo
scottare possiamo perderci possiamo fare
del bene a stare male
come li usiamo per migliorarci la vita
dipende solo da noi e come useremo lo
smart work in per migliorare la vita
dipende solo da noi non possiamo più
negarne l'esistenza ma imparare a usarlo
sì per migliorare la nostra
insomma è solo un altro potentissimo
strumento che ci sta regalando delle
potentissime opportunità
usiamo le per il nostro bene per il bene
di chi ci circonda
per la nostra crescita anche economica
e per il benessere di questo pianeta che
in fondo ci sta solo ospitando
insomma
siamo nel bel mezzo di un evento epocale
e io provo finalmente la sensazione di
poter ri progettare il futuro con
entusiasmo e anche con tanta curiosità
non avete anche voi questa percezione
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]